Brendan uh schaab Saga has been great
but one of the things that we've loved
covering the most and we brought this up
once the brand is something kind of
boring
was covering the uh Mark Harley had
known in this show that's a big a lion
or uh GL baby bgl all day
um begin line
um there's a lot of stuff that's coming
out okay
I want to be fair and I'm seriously
because we do want to be fair because it
is true that you're going to see there's
that video that we're about to see and I
think we'll play it in the order that
most people have seen it right
um there's this video right here
just quick background believe
um I've been so wild ride I believe that
what's going on here this is the part
one the fight Haven put up and [__] like
that I believe that what you're seeing
here is he cheated on her but she's all
but what I've also found out is she's
also cheated on him so these two cheat
on each other toxic mess yeah it's one
of those that got that everyone knows a
couple like that you know or some people
have been in this a couple like I was
gonna say or except frequently a couple
like that yeah and I know okay
but Mercy is never to give credit to him
deadlifted a [__] car
it's yeah okay that's so it's never gone
to that point mostly because my back
wouldn't screen it if you look over her
shoulder it looks like a horror film
this looks like a freeze someone's gonna
someone's gonna recut it into that they
have to right here we go he's in front
of my car he's touching my car now he's
picking up my car he's picking up my car
as you can see he's picking up my car he
doesn't let me go
okay this is insane
you know he hit it
Shane let me go he doesn't let me just
[__] go he doesn't let me go he's
attacking me he's attacking me well he's
hitting in the car he's been attacking
you papa DMS DMS okay oh no the gifts
already already
what I got it pulling it up do the video
again with that do the video again with
that yes
I gotta check out you give me a second
give me a second I got you here we go I
got you let me get the song [__] that
yes great choice we could we could do
this one [__] that we could do it we
don't need anyone to do it here we go
start from the beginning
you got to skip ahead a little bit yeah
it's right around I got it it goes right
here
right around here there you go oh trust
me I know this song
he's picking up my car I feel sweet
as you can see he's picking up my car he
doesn't let me go
hit it
he doesn't let me go he doesn't let me
just [__] go he doesn't let it go he's
attacking me he's attacking me
he's attacking me
it's so fantastic
he just did this
that was very funny
you're welcome so they're doing good
yeah we're doing really great the
movie's called 28 grams of steroids
later
um
28 Cycles later yeah 28 Cycles later
there it is oh no I gotta say Mark
um you're acting like a real n person so
here's the problem though that's his
quote not mine by the way I remember he
was yeah I talked about end people and S
people you're acting like now of course
looking at that he looks crazy but the
problem is is that relationships are
two-sided are they not
yeah generally speaking what is wrong
with you I love you
can do it this way no no it's over no no
no mark
stop this no it's me
you said you want to win me back
please get off me please get off me oh
boy my dude got a selfie yo yo side boob
side Boop oh we are getting some signs
by the way you gotta imagine she's
probably [__] it of course because she's
like some athlete too right
get off me please
get off me I would not let her mouth
that close to my face or earbud
please get off me
um man dude I've been there I know that
level of crazy but you're like literally
trying to calmly leave and they like
foot sterically crap onto you I'm gonna
kill myself like God damn I just want to
get out of here can I can I can I say we
I will sympathize with Mark on that
because anyone that's ever been in one
of these situations like right here been
there bro it sucks DNT production goes
you have stage five stage five Clinger
bro 100 percent
maybe Mark wasn't trying to keep her
from leaving maybe he was making sure
that she would go
maybe that's why he was kicking the car
so she would leave bro this is like here
dude this is one of those where you
eventually have to be like all right
honey honey relax I'm just going outside
to have a cigarette
it's all good and then you have to slip
out the door quietly now just to show
fairness it's equal in the sexes
yep
please get off me
bro I bet she [__] like a champ though
of course she does [__] get ready for
this here we go
there we go um
the way I see it you need an accuser
right like the victim has to accuse I'm
not accusing anything
that's
um it sounds like you kinda are though
kind of starting to think that oh what's
this thank you for this Fergie by the
way
um
Let's uh
have some fun what do you say you want
to go down memory lane with them
I think we should go down memory lane
let me pull this up for everybody here
you go let's go down memory lane hey hey
merge merch look at all them dots up
there in that story oh yeah yeah let me
know when I should start the campaign
now the campaign that she's referring to
is Mark is now starting a smear campaign
against me let's continue there's no
sound in this one there will be in a
couple coming up uh that's her IG she
blocked me that's the person that
according to her Mark cheated on her
with if I correct yes yes the girl
message me threatening me keep it up I
have videos of you doing crazy [__] I
have no empathy
for you I will not hesitate I bet she
also didn't show like how many messages
she probably sent to that chick an
arrest can lead to deportation oh this
is getting nice okay yeah this was the
girlfriend that yeah she showed she said
the girl was harassing her right but she
only showed a couple screenshots where
the side [__] was basically saying yo
leave me the [__] alone you're harassing
me and I don't [__] with your
immigration status if I want to report
this [__] like she didn't show all the
messages she probably sent to her first
this says hot can i p p hay thanks for
your help with the laundry babe I really
appreciate it okay
hold on because there's oh
where's okay hold on yo this [__] is
crazy
yo hold on here you go here you go here
you go
the reason I'm speaking about this
publicly
I have a private IG so it's not that
publicly but
um you know is because he is a public
figure uh he has made me part of his
public persona he has I don't even know
you existed until today honey to be
honest yeah I didn't even know he was
married honestly and I didn't care so
where are you just like making fun of
his dumb muscles and his gay Mane yeah
this is like uh hold on we got oh
now it does just seem like they're both
terrible people oh yeah you think then
explain this
stop
okay yeah that's starting to think that
um this is a little more two-sided there
huh I think it's even once I think it's
leading yeah yeah I'm with you and look
I don't I'm not a big gay lion uh fan
I'm not gonna be his advocate here
um especially since he went and did
other shows and not ours
um well he said we had to ask him I just
don't want to do that yeah I was not
going to go through that anyway it seems
like we really are it seems like a whole
thing I'm not gonna ask politely just do
it or don't I don't care um I'm not
gonna beg for [__] you know what I mean
and I'm not gonna beg to get bgl on my
show like if you want to go in the car
and [__] cool but we're not making a
whole thing that's exactly that's how
that's what got Brandon Trump in trouble
yeah no but like by the way who I'm on
his side right now I have to go Brendan
even though he blocked me and it's okay
buddy I'm with you Redemption Arc here
Brendan Schaub knew how toxic Mark the
mark stuff was coming out and he cut him
out of his life because he's becoming a
better person
no I don't know I think you I think he
[__] up you cut Mark Carly out now you
have no Brendan you have no Brian Callan
anymore either
you have his late you know what I call
bro you know what he said you know what
I call Brian Callan dead weight
all right let's face it who carried that
show
Papa did Papa did the producer the Asian
guy okay the technically yes but Papa
carried the [__] Comedy
All right so that's two but the third
one on the list
I
don't know
I don't think Mark Harley I mean we did
see him kicking on the car and [__] but
I don't see him as being like a
physically abusive guy no but I do think
he has been pushed to the [__] Brink
no he does you'll see he does oh does he
oh boy she did right yeah
she grabbed his hair and he acts like
it's made out of [__] nerve ending
well that's because he's filming himself
and he wanted to make it look now
there's this part so here you go no no
forgive me I will never forgive you
forgive you for what tell him the truth
no forget
it
dude yeah I got the entire exchange on
video
I know I didn't like this you were on
top of me and I went like that you just
hidden Luana okay Luana that's when a
girl hits you and then pretends you hit
her anything you just like oh my God
just so like to make it to be like make
it even I have it all on video so
they're going to watch that we're going
to watch that
well we're gonna watch that here's the
thing right like I don't
I've been in situations where a chick
got physical
and it's that's it after that we're done
I don't allow it to go like I highly
encourage men and women if you're in a
relationship the first time it gets
physical like that just can't be done
with it because it's never gonna
de-esque like it's never gonna get
better and I don't want to live in a
household where I'm worried I'm going to
be physically struck like that now you
know now you know how Dayton hypernova
felt now you feel bad don't you yeah
no but it's like it just I feel like
that's a basic you know like the left
always talks about like uh human rights
and like you know medical rights or
human rights how about the basic human
right of I should be able to come home
and not get hit in the face I should be
able to get struck in my home well this
is one of her videos December 2015 he
hits me for the first time in the face
beats me in this house at his mom's
house after I asked him to help me with
my green card application
now my first physical abuse first hit in
the face where's she from Canada is that
what it is no she's like Russia or
something you're [__] intolerable
I mean I mean I understand he's using it
I've been watching she does seem that
way nice side boob though you're [__]
intolerable
you're [__]
intolerable and then you call me a
little [__]
I mean yeah you're kind of being a
little [__] you're being a [__]
you're both being [__] but you know
you'll be a little [__] [__] too I
think this calls for one of them
patented ROTC hate hates yeah this is
one of those patterns also you know also
copyright add that to our cringe talk
list what do you say yeah there you go
thank you and then you maybe we should
go around the world with it you thought
that check mark wasn't going to cost you
anything Adonis yeah it cost you
everything
nice tune anyways
on my mind
like you the [__] out of my life okay
whatever I want so do it you start
remembering that a little bit more
so you're threatening you're basically
saying here's what could happen that's
not a threat that's a promise because
they're asking you what uh to help me
out that's a promise
hit me
oh wait wait wait wait wait a second did
he okay hold on what did he just did he
slap her or yeah he gave her a little
tap smackaroo oh it's like a little Sean
Connery slap hummus a reset is that
asking you what uh to help me out that's
a promise
hit me
[__] that was an ID that was like a
nudge oh that was like you know when you
hit a kid in the back of the head when
he's being a dork yeah it's like when
you get somebody's forehead and you give
him one of those yeah you know you give
him a little shove you're like yeah I'm
a [__] boy
it's tell me these things
are the [__] I want you just told me
with some knowledge [__] I'm Mark
Harley pseudo intellectual whatever that
means I don't know I haven't looked it
up yet haters will say big gay lion they
call me n person
[Laughter]
call me Gray Maine
they call me the bouncer at PF Changs
they call me light boy they call me I
said sugar and cream yes foreign
they call me hey white boy put this
dress on for BT
they call me peanut Arbuckle
oh yeah you want to throw me out a
window yeah I do well I kind of do too I
mean yeah me too honestly I mean me too
just to remind you you're nothing to me
okay you hear that you're nothing to me
and when you reinforce that idea with
your behavior and yesterday and all the
[__] you say to me
oh the [__] you say oh this should you
say running through my head okay but
here's the thing right yeah bgl then
leave
well where's he gonna live
is she the one oh boy oh you're a little
grain of sand but I'm gonna [__] kick
out of the window so how the [__] why
did you uh why are you [__] me every
night
I mean the sides a little hot we saw the
side boob that's the reason you're still
hot hold on ma'am I'll tell you why he's
still [__] you because it's your only
redeeming quality so if I'm gonna get
hit and get screened at no no I'm gonna
get I'm gonna get my dick wet I'm gonna
get my dick away wrong way I think he's
dating a hot crazy chick boy
yeah but it's like yeah I'm putting up
with the getting hit and the being
demeaned and and like having videos put
out calling me an abuser and [__] and
all the guests I put up with that
because I [__] you every night yeah
that's the deal
we got a uh by the way an eight dollar
uh five dollar hype train all right
virgie's on fire today back on the smack
hype train
[__] [__]
second of all he has not been on fire
today so relax yeah it's neither of
those things are true
not even slightly
telling me all these cute things okay
because you're there so maybe you
shouldn't have gotten married to me I
that's the thing we all agree on I think
I shouldn't have gotten married to you
shouldn't have manipulated me with uh
suicide
buddy we've all been with a chick that
threatened suicide let's not you know
it's called being with a woman yeah
oh I'm sorry I'm sorry have you have you
have you never been on a date we know
what it is
Mark you handle it the way all this real
men handle it if a woman commits
threatens to commit suicide you go in
your bedroom you get your gun you wipe
all your prints off of it and you hand
it to her okay here you go
and guess what the best part is Mark
they never do it they never do it Put
the gun down right in front of them go
ahead they never do it it's hilarious
uh and then they'll call the cops and
[__] accuse you for brandishing a
fire yeah
God damn it look officer she said she
wanted to kill herself I was helping her